[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
عبد القادر عياد في الوقت الذي احدث
وتطور اخرى في مناطقه مختلفه من العالم
هنا في كورنيش الدار البيضاء
على بلجيكا في اليوم الثامن من منافسات
كاس العالم لكره القدم
[موسيقى]
ثم الى العاصمه الصوماليه مقديش انفجاران
في فندق بالقرب من القصر الرئاسي يقيم فيه
نواب في البرلمان ومسؤولون في الحكومه
حركه الشباب المجاهدين تبنت العمليه
ومن واشنطلون هذه الصور في وقت اعلن فيه
عن خساره كبيره لتويتر بانسحاب نصف عدد
كبار البؤلين فيها بينما يقولوا مدير منصه
ان اعداد مستخدميها تتزايد بالطراد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
التركيه في شمال سوريا والعراق تتصاعد
القوه التركيه توسع قصفها لمواقع من سمتهم
بالارهابيين
والفصائل الكرديه تتحدث عن تعرض مطار حلب
وعيد العرب كوباني ومناطق في الرقه
والحسكه لقصف التركي ووسط خلافات مع روسيا
ومطالب امريكيه بالتهدئه الرئيس التركي
يؤكد انه ليس بامكان احد منعه بلاده من
التحرك خارج حدودها لضمان امنيها
[موسيقى]
احتدام المعارك على كامل خط الجبهه في
اقليم ميدنيتك ونوغاز
موسكو تقول انها صدتها هجمات
والقوات الاوكرانيه تضرب خطوط امداد بين
القرد
وبريطانيا تعلن تزويد بصواريخ ارض جو
عاليه الدقه وتؤكد لاعبها دورا حاسما في
عرقله التقدم الروسي
من بيجين الى شنغهاي الى اوغان بؤره ظهور
كورونا الصين تشهد احتجاجات واسعه وتقارير
تصفها بالاكبر من نوعها رفضا لاجراءات
الحكومه المستمره منذ ثلاث سنوات لمكافحه
كورونا وسط اشتباكات مع الامن واعتقالات
وهتافات تهاجم الحزب الشيوعي وتطالب
الرئيس بالاستقاله
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه يكون قد ناقشنا معكم ملابسات
خساره تويتر نحو اثني عشر مليار دولار
بتوقف 50 من اكبر مئه معلن فيها عن
التعامل معها منذ استحواذ ايلون ماسك
عليها قبل 25 يوما استطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي ما مستقبل منصه في ضوء خساره نصف
عدد المؤللين فيها اثنان واربعون في المئه
توقعوا ان يقتصر الامر على خسائر ماليه
محدوده بينما قالت 22% ان الخسائر ستؤثر
على توسع تويتر وانتشارها وراى 36% ان
المساله ستؤدي لاعادته بيعه تويتر
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا في منصه الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودونيه
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه 12
و 5 دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه تتابعون
الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات المونديال
التي ترصد بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس
العالم قطر 2002 2022
في وقت تتزايد فيه مؤشراته عمليه بريه
تركيه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع في انقره
مواصلتها قصف مواقع من سمتهم الارهابيين
الشمالي سوريا والعراق وقالت ان جنديا
تركيا فارق الحياه متاثرا باصابته برصاص
حزب العمال الكردستاني في العمليه
العسكريه الجاريه شمالي العراق ونشرت
وزاره الدفاع التركيه عبر حسابها على
تويتر بشاهد القصف المدفعي الذي استهدف
تلك المواقع
في المقابل قالت وكاله هوار القريبه
بالحزب العمال الكردستاني ان الجيش التركي
يواصل قصفه الكثيف بالطائرات الحربيه
والمسيره والاسلحه الثقيله على مختلف
مناطق شذى وشرقي سوريا وذكرت الوكاله ان
القصف استهدف مطار منه في ريفي حلب وقريه
عين دجله في منطقه الشهباء وقريه مرعنات
في عفرين بينما ذكر المركز الاعلامي لما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ان القوات
التركيه شنظ ضربات بالقذائف على عين العرب
كوباني الابيض باكثر من 400 قذفتها ودبابه
كما ذكرت وسائل الاعلام مواليه لما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ان القصف التركيه
استهدف قرى عده بريف الحسكه ورقه مشتركه
لهذه القوات وقوات النظام السوري بمحيطي
عين العرب كوباني ما اسفر عن اصابه عنصر
تابع لقوات النظام
هذا والتقى وزير الدفاع تركيا خلص يا اكار
قادت الجيش في مدينه هاكاري على الحدود
العراقيه وسبق الاجتماعي الذي احتضنه مركز
قياده الفرقه البريه الثالثه فيها كاري
اجتماع الليلي امس لاذكار مع قاده الجيش
في مقر قياده القوات البريه بالعاصمه
انقره
لمرات عده تعلن تركيا ان هدف عمليتها
العسكريه عمليتها العسكريه شماليه سوريا
هو اقامه حزام امني من الغرب الى الشرق
على طول حدودها الجنوبيه والجنوبيه
الشرقيه مع كل من سوريا والعراق لكن
العمليه العسكريه الاخيره بدت وفق محللين
مراهنه على استكمال هذا الهدف مركزه على
محاور تبرز فيها كل من عين العرب كوباني
لا يمكن فصله ما تسميه انقره حاليا بعمليه
المخلب السيف عن عمليه سابقه ولها عمليه
الدرع الفرات التي استمرت قرابه سبعه اشهر
وانتهت في مارس اذار 2017
وسيطرت خلالها المعارضه السوريه بدعم تركي
على اعزاز وجرابلس ومدينه الباب بريف حلب
الشرقي وجاءت لعمليه العسكريه الثانيه غصن
الزيتون في يناير 2018
للسيطره على مدينه عفرين السوريه واستمرت
اربعه اشهر وفي اكتوبر عام 2019 كانت
عمليه نبع السلام وجاء بعد هاتف قسوتشي
بين تركيا وروسيا ونص على الاحتفاظ بالوضع
القائم وتحكم تركي في عمق نحو 30 كلم من
الحدود شامل ابيض وراس العين
محاور المعركه دائره حاليا يمكن ان تتلخص
في ثلاث جبهات وهي عين العرب كوباني و
منبر جوا وسيل رفعت وهي مناطق تغلب عليها
الطبيعه السهليه دون وجود جبال صعبه او
معقده تؤدي السيطره على عين العرب كوباني
الى وصل منطقه النبع السلام ومنطقه درع
الفرات التي تتضمن اعزاز بوصفها عاصمه
لمؤسسه المعارضه عسكريا وسياسيا واقتصاديا
في الشمال السوري القائد العام لما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي كان
قال ان تركيا تريد الاستيلاء على عين
العرب كوباني
بمدينه اعزاز شماليه حلب ومدن اخرى يعني
ذلك حرمان وحدث حمايه الشعب الكرديه من
حاضنه ومدينه اخذت اسم العالميا حين بدات
تحالف الدولي وحربه على تنظيم الدوله
وسيحرم ما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه من
اهم معاقدها على الحدود السوريه التركيه
بين نهري الخبور والفرات وقد اتهامتها
انقر باستهداف المدن الحدوديه التركيه
انطلاقا منها بقضاء في الهاون والمدفعيه
اما منبج المحور الثاني فتشكل اكبر معقل
لما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه غربيه
الفرات وبالنسبه لمحور فيتضمن مطار مننا
العسكري في ريف حلب وبلده دير جمال وعشره
الكره الصغيره في محيطهما وهذه المنطقه
بمثابه عازل بين قوه المعارضه في اعزاز
وقوه النظام الشمال حلب
اذن تركيا ماضيه قدما في عمليتها العسكريه
في شماليه سوريا تاكيد جاء على لسان
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الذي قال
انه ليس لاحد ان يقف امام بلاده في ممارسه
حقها والتحرك خارج حدودها وجاء هذا
التصريح في اعقاب قصف تركيا اهداف او
استهدف مواقع للاكراد في مدن عده بالشمال
السوري تطورات تلقي تلقى اعتراضا روسيا
وامريكا حيث اكد الكريم لم وجوده خلافات
مع انقره بشان عمليتها العسكريه لكنه قال
ان حلها سيكون عبر اجراء محادثه
مفترق وطرق وضعت فيه العمليه العسكريه
التركيه مخلب السيف كل من روسيا والولايات
المتحده وتركيا وساحه التجارب المواقف هي
سوريا في مناطقها الشماليه الشرقيه
تمت خلافات مؤكده بين انقره وموسكو بشان
التحرك التركي قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
سكوف لكنها من نوع الخلافات التي يمكن
حلها بالحكمه السياسيه ليس الموقف الروسي
وليد الساعه فقد سبق بدا تركيا عمليتها
العسكريه عندما طلبت موسكو من انقره
الامتناع عن شم هجوم بري شامل لان ذلك قد
يؤدي الى تصاعد العنف من وجهه نظر الروس
يتهم الرسل الولايات المتحده بانها وراء
تاليب المسلحين الاكراد الذين تعتبرهم
انقره تهديدا لامنها فقد قال مبعوث الرئيس
الروسي الى الشرق الاوسط وشمالي افريقيا
اليكساندر لافرنتيف ان الغرب يعتبر سوريا
جبهه اضافيه ضد روسيا في ظل استمرار الحرب
في اوكرانيا لكن الولايات المتحده ايضا
عارضت لعمليه العسكريه
البنتاجون طالب انقر بوقفها فورا لانها من
منظور امريكي تهدد امن الجنود الامريكيين
ففي مواقع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه التي
يستهدفها القصف التركي يتوزع حوالي 900
جندي امريكي في اطار التحالف الدولي ضد
تنظيم الدوله الذي يشكل الاكراد حجرا
اساسيا فيها رغم ذلك سبق للبيت الابيض ان
ابدى موقفا متفهما لبواعث القلق التركي
وقال انه يحق للاتراك الدفاع عن انفسهم من
اي تهديد ارهابيه
ايا كانت المواقف فين الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان بدا حازما عازما على المضيق
قدما عندما قال ان لبلاده حقا مشروعه وانه
ليس لاحد ان يقف امام ممارسه حقها
على الارض وصلت القوات التركيه قصف مواقع
من وصفتهم بالارهابيين شمالي سوريا
والعراق وحددت مصادر اعلاميه قريبه من حزب
العمال الكردستاني اهداف القصف التركي في
مطار منا في ريف حلب وقريه عين دقنه في
منطقه الشهباء وقريه مرعناز في عفرين
بينما قال المركز الاعلامي لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ان ضربات بالقذائف والهاون
والدبابات استهدفه الفرات وعين العرب
كوباني وتل ابيض باكثر من 400 قذيفه
تطورات رافقها تحرك وزير الدفاع التركي
خلصي اكار الذي التقى قادت الجيش في
مدينتها كاري على الحدود العراقيه لمتابعه
مجريات العمليتين العسكريتين التركيتين في
سوريا والعراق
ورحب بضيفيه من موسكو يبقيني يا سيدي روفر
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وبضيفه من انقر
الدكتوره شوي شيكلين الاستاذه في جامعه
هجي بيرم في انقره وابدا معك الدكتوره
الشكالين عن محاوله فهم الموقف التركي
الان هذه ليست اول مره تهدد فيها تركيا
بشان عمليات بريه واقامه هذا الحزام
الامني ما الذي يختلف الان في ظل الموقف
الروسي والامريكي المعلن
ثانكيو فور كويس
في الحقيقه ان تركيا
تقاتلوا الارهابيين على مدى السنوات
الثلاث الماضيه خصوصا بعد العام 2016 كان
هناك ثلاث عمليات
ميدانيه في سوريا وهذا القتال ضد الارهاب
كما على الرئيس التركي يعتمد على ركنين
اولا القضاء على الارهابيين في مكانهم في
معاقلهم بعد الحدود التركيه والنقطه
الثانيه هي ان السبب الشرعي الذي يسمح
لتركيا ان تقوم بذلك هو الدفاع عن النفس
وفقا للماده الحاده والخمسين
المتحده وبالتالي الموقف التركي لم يتغير
هناك
تنظيمات ارهابيه بدات في العام 2011 بظهور
في سوريا
واعلن تركيا انها لن تسمح ابدا بممر
ارهابيه على حدودها واليوم تركيا تود ان
اا من خلال هذا العمليات وادي تركيا ان
تقول ان باستطاعتها ان تشن عمليه جويه
وايضا داخل الحدود السوريه والعراقيه
والرئيس التركي ذكر بشكل واضح
بان تركيا تود تنفيذ الاتفاقيه بين
الولايات المتحده وتركيا وروسيا
وتركيا سيد امام
عايز يوتيوب
عن القيام بعمليات بريه اسال ضيفي من
اموسكو والسيد ااا سيديروف
خلافات حقيقيه مع الجانب التركي وتقول ان
حلها ياتي بالحوار الحوار وفقا اي قاعده
قواعد بينها وبين الجانب التركي اي ارضيه
تحياتي اهلا وسهلا
انا اعتقد بان الحوار الذي يتحدث عنه او
تتحدث عنه موسكو يمكن ان يكون ويستمر على
نفس الاسس الذي كان قائما قبل ذلك اي وفقا
للاتفاقيات السابقه التي تم تواصل اليه
بين موسكو وتركيا سواء في سوشي عام 2019
او قبلها الان الرئيس التركي اردوغان
يستاهل موسكو بانها لا تنفذه
وعودها بوعودها والتزاماتها وفقا لهذا
الاتفاق ولكن هذا باراي موسكو غير صحيح
لان تركيا في نفس الوقت في تعهداتها في
الفصل ما بين المعارضه السوريه المعتدله
وبين الارهابيين طبعا هذا الامر ربما ليس
له علاقه مباشره بالعمليه العسكريه التي
تاخذها تركيا الان ولكنه يؤثر سلبا على
العلاقات
جروب همم من تصفه موسكو بالارهابي ومن
تصفه بغير ارهابي
انا اتحدث مثلا عن منطقه ادلب حيث روسيا
ترى انه كان على تركيا عن تقوم بكل
الاجراءات اللازمه للفصل بين من تعتبرهم
الارهابيين اي عناصر جبهه النصره وغيرها
من التنظيمات المصنف ارهابيا وبين همم
المعارضه المعارضه السوريه المعتدله يعني
هذه الالتزامات تركيا لم ااه طافيه بها
حتى الان
كلامك
ان همم
الجانب التركي يقول اننا قدمت لنا ضمنات
ولم يتم الايفاء بهذه الالتزامات هل نفهم
من ذلك ان عدم التزام تركيا معناها عدم
التزام الطرف الاخر وتحديدا هو الجانب
الروسي
لا اليس هذا فقط هو انما انا كنت اقصد
بكلامي انه فيما اذا واجه تركي اتهامات
جديده الى موسكو بانها ليطافي بالجزاماتها
السابقه وفقا مثلا الاتفاقات التي تم
التوصل اليه في السوشي روسيا يمكنها ردا
على ذلك ان تذكرها بالالتزامات التركيه
السابقه على اي حال الوضع الان يتطلب ربما
مشاورات عاجله بين موسكو وانقره على مختلف
المستويات حتى ربما على مستوى الدفاع
الدكتوره
شيكلين فيما تتطرف السيدروف في فهم الموقف
الروسي وهم ستقوم تركيا بهذه العمليات
البريه رغم الموقف الروسي المعلن ورغم
الموقف الامريكي ايضا المعلق
اه تنكس فورد كويس
[موسيقى]
بناء على ما قاله الرئيس اردوغان في
الاسبوع الماضي يبدو ان تركيا سوف تشد
عمليه ميدانيه بريه في سوريا ولكن لا نعرف
التوقيت بناء على العمليات الثلاث السابقه
راينا ان العلم الغربي وروسيا لم يدعموا
جميعا العمليات التركيه ولكن تركيا قامت
بالعمليات السابقه
شكرا جزيلا لك من انقره الدكتوره شوي
شيكاليين الاستاذ في جامعه في انقره وكذلك
الشكل ضيفي من موسكو الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي
[موسيقى]
على طول خطي الجبهه في اقليم دومباز في
شرق اوكرانيا تحتدم المعارك اما خيرسون في
الجنوب و تشهدوا قصفا اوكرانيا روسيا
متبادلا رغم الانسحاب الروسي منها تحاول
القوات الاخرانيه ضربه طرق الامداد بين
نهر الدينيه برو وشبه جزيره القرن في حين
تسعى القوات الروسيه الى ضرب البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه كما افاد الجيش
الاخراني ان قصفا روسيا مكثفا استهدفا
بنيته التحتيه
بمقاطعه وسط جنوب جنوبيه اوكرانيا اضافه
الى تعرضه اذا واحد ظروفها لقصف بالصواريخ
دون وقوعه صباحا
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها صدتها جامعه اوكرانيه على محورين
دونيسكو ولوجاز وقد بثت قوات الدنيا
المواليه لروسيا صورا لما قالت انه
استهدافه جنود اوكرانيين حاولوا اقتحام
مواقع روسيه وتظهر المقاطع رصد واستهدف
مجموعه تابعه للقوات الاخرانيه حاولت
اقتحام مواقع روسيه في مكان غير محدد في
الاقليم
هذا واعلن حاكم ودنياسك الاوكراني مقتل
مدنيين الاثنين واصابه اخر جراء اقصف
مدفعي روسي على مدينه كانخوفا جنوبيه
مدينه دونيزك واشار الحاكم الى ان القصف
الحق اضرار باربعه مباني في المدينه متهما
روسيا بتعمد استهدافه المدنيين
اما فيه لوجان
الحاكم الاوكراني الاقليم صورا قال انها
لاليات روسيه مدمره على الطريق الواصلي
بين مدينتي كوبيانس بمقاطعه
توضا حيث ذكرت قياده الاركاد الاخرانيه ان
قوتها صدق خمسه محاولات روسيه للتقدم في
المقاطاعتين ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر
عسكريه اوكرانيه ان محور سوريا شمال شرق
باخموت والمحور الشرقي لمدينه الدقه يشهد
لمعارك عنيفه اسفرت عن سقوط 10
الروسيه بين قتيل وجريح
متابعه اللي كل هذه التطورات البدنيه نظم
الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاسترجي اهلا بك حضره العميد
اذا اشتداد يوما بعد يوم لهذه المعارك كيف
وجدت هذه التطورات العسكريه في هذه
المنطقه ذكرها قبل قليل
عبد القادر بعد الانسحاب من خرسان مرحله
جديده يعني مسرح الحرب تبدل اصبح نهر
النيترو هو الفاصل بين الشمال او الغرب
والشرق اليوم هناك مقاربتان للجيش الروسي
واحده في اقليم خرسون ما تبقى خرسان في
الجنوب وحتى من اليوتيوب بول زبالهوجيا
الدفاعات هي الاساس اليوم هو يعتمد مركز
الدفاع الاساسي لانه يعتبر ان هذه المنطقه
هي حيويه جدا هي الجسر البري الذي ياخذ
الى الدمباز الى ماريو بول وياخذ الى شبه
جزيره القرم من هنا هذا الموضوع الرد
دائما عبر الهايمارس او السلاح البعيد
المدى ضرب اللوجستيه وبشكل ان تمنع الجيش
الروسي من التمكن من تركيب جهازيه عسكريه
للمرحله اللاحقه اما الشرق فهناك يعني
الموضوع مختلف تماما
طيب هناك ايضا في الاخبار التي معنا علقنا
عن الايكونوميز عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه
انه لا خطاطه حاليا لدينا لاستعاده اراضي
استولت عليها روسيا قبل تاريخ الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير الالماني الحديث عن عن
ال ال القرم كيف وجدت هذا البعد
القرم عبد القادر هي امر صعب جدا هي
اساسيه للرئيس بوتين يعتبرها حيويه من هنا
كانت تردد الفعل عندما همم استهدف جسر كرش
استرداد القرم يتطلب ذخيره يتطلب عتاب
يتطلب عديد مهم جدا لانه عندما نتحدث عن
اوكرانيا انما تتحدث عن المساحات الكبيره
والطرقات الكبيره التي تتجاوز ما يقارب
يعني مئات الكيلومترات وهذا امر ليس متوفر
حاليا اليوم اعتقد ان الفريقين يحدران
لمرحله قادمه هي مرحله ما بعد الشتاء
اليوم في تراجع بالرغم من هذا الحديث عن
يعني هل هذا التوتر هناك تراجع بانتظار ان
يستقر الثلج وياتي الجليد تصبح امكانيه
الحركيه اكثر قد تتزايد العمليه العسكريه
خاصه
للسؤال عن نوعيه الاسلحه
الايطاليون يتكلمون عن تزويد مواصله تزويد
الجانب الاوكراني
باسلحه نوعيه بانها هي من تصنع الفرق في
هذه المواجهات الى اي مدى نوعيه الاسلحه
حاسمه في تحديد ما يجري على الارض
مررنا في مرحله عبد القادر هاي مارس كان
جزء اساسي من وقف العمليات الهجوميات
استهدف البنا التحتيه مراكز ذكيه زخيره
وحتى القياده والسيطره يبقى عبد القادر
الحجم الذي سيعطي من هذا السلاح
ادخاله في المنظومه العسكريه الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي هل يمكن للغرب ان يعطي دون حساب
وهو ايضا بدا يعاني من النقص في المخازن
الذخيره وبدات تكليف المصانع لانتاج
المزيد من الذخيره الاستهلاك كبير جدا على
الساحه الاكرانيه عبد القادر شكرا جزيلا
لك الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العميد
الياس عنا كنت معنا من بيروت
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه عبر حسابها
الرسمي في تويتر ان المملكه المتحده قدمت
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه صواريخ ارض جو
عاليه الدقه من طراز برنستون 2 كجزء من
حزمه مساعداتها العسكريه لاوكرانيا وقالت
الوزاره ان هذه الحزمه من المساعدات لعب
دورا حاسما في عرقله التقدم الروسيه
هو صاروخ هجومي يطلق من الارض او الجو ثم
تطويره لسلاح الجو الملكيه البريطاني كان
الغرض منه في الاصل هو استخدامه مع
اعتقاليه اطلق واا ضد التشكيلات الضخمه من
مدرعات العدو ونجحت القوات والاكرانيه في
تعديله لاستخدامه من من الصبريه ضد القوات
الروسيه
يعد هذا الفيديو اجابه طال انتظارها عن
السؤال كيف ستطلق القوات الاوكرانيه
صواريخ قبل ايام قليله فقط كان هناك اول
دليل على ان الاوكرانيين يستخدمون بالفعل
بريميسيون لتدمير الاصول العسكري الروسيه
ولكن الصاروخ مصمم لاطلاقه من الجو وجرى
تحسين هذا الصاروخ ايضا من قبل مختصين
بريطانيين لاطلاقه ارضيه
صممت هذه الصواريخ شركه تصنيع سلاح تشترك
فيها دول اوروبيه
تعني الكبريت باللغه العربيه اساسا لتكون
مضاده للدروع ومع الوقت تطورت لتستطيع
تدمير تشكيله واسعه من الاهداف
يذكرون اثنين هو عباره عن صاروخ جو ارض
يحلق الى مسافه 60 كم عند اطلاقه من
الطائره اما في حال اطلاقه من منصه دريه
فلا يتجاوز مدى عمله 12 كيلومترا يبلغ وزن
الراس الحربي سته كيلو غرامات 3600 غرام
ودخل الخدمه في يوليو 2016
ويكلف كل صاروخ الحكومه البريطانيه 2007
الاف دولار بينما لم تذكر لندن عدد
الصواريخ التي سترسلها الى الجيش
الاوكراني
مدن صينيه عده ابرزها شنغهاي وبيجين
مظاهرات رافضه للقيود الصارمه التي تفرضها
الحكومه في ايطاليا سياسه صفر كوفد وردد
المحتجون هتافات نادرا ما تسمع في الصين
وسط التدخل قوات الامن لتفريقهم واعتقان
بعضهم وتعيش البلاد منذ نحو ثلاث سنوات
بعضا من اكثر قيود صرامه في العالم
[تصفيق]
بيضاء على قارعه الطريق اصوروا قليله
واحيانا لا تعمر كثيرا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
في العاصمه الاقتصاديه للبلاد رددت حناجر
المتظاهرين هتافات نادرا ما تسمعه هنا
كانت ضد الحزب الشيوعي والرئيس الذي طلبه
بالاستقاله عشيه يوم الغضب سجلت الاصابات
بكرونا مستوى قياسيا اخر اذ بلغت ما يقرب
من اربعين الف حاله تخضع شنغهاي لاغلاق
تام منذ شهرين تجد السلطات الصينيه صعوبه
في التعايش مع الفيروس كباقي دول العالم
تدخلت الشرطه لتفريق المتظاهرين واعتقلت
عددا منهم
في بيجين عبره مئات الطلبه في جامعه شيخه
المرموقه عن استيائهم من الاجراءات
الصارمه للحد من فيروس كوفيت 19
للاختبارات البي سي ار ولا للاغلاق حظرت
السلطات الوسمه المرتبطه بالاحتجاجات
عالمي منصه ويبو وحذفت مقاطع فيديو من
مواقع صينيه تفجر الغضب من القيود
المستمره منذ نحو ثلاث سنوات على ظهور
الجائحه وعيد الحريق الذي نشب في بنايات
مرتفعه باورنج عاصمه اقليم يوم الجمعه
الماضيه قتل فيه 10 اشخاص عن الاقل حمل
النشطون اجراءات الاغلاق التي منعت وفقهم
الناس من الهرب مسؤوليه ارتفاع عدد ضحايا
امرا تنفيه السلطات المحليه تدافع بيجين
عن سياسه السفر بالقول ان هدفها انقاذ
الارواح وانها ضروريه لعدم الضغط على نظام
الصحيه بما يفوق طاقته
الفايروس تراجعها ولم يختفي تماما تذكره
تقارير منظمه الصحه العالميه المتفائله
نسبيا في الشهور الاخيره تفائل لا يبدو
انه كاف
لسلطات البيجين من اجل عوده الحياه الى
طبيعتها بعد سنوات من الاجراءات القاسيه
التي استنفدت لدى الكثيرين القدره على
تحملها هل سيدفع الغضب الشعبي الى تخفيف
القيود ام الى فرض قيود النوع اخر
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من لندن مارتن جاك استاذ
الدراسات الدوليه بجامعه كامبردج والزميله
الاول في معهد الصين بجامعه فودان اهلا بك
بروفيسور جاك كيف وجدت هذه المظاهرات في
الصين
وخصوصا الشباب
في اوساط المجتمع الصيني
ويصعب ان نعرف عدد المدن التي تاثرت حتى
اللحظه ولكن هذا مبعث قلق بالنسبه الى
السلطات الصينيه هل السبب الوحيد فقط هو
الذجر من هذه الاجراءات بعض الهتافات
تنادي باسقاط الحزب الشيوعي الحاكم
يا عيني
من الخطا ان ان يفسر ما يحصل في سياق
سياسي وفي مهاجمه لا الحزب الشيوعي
الاصلي
جدا طبعا قد يكون هناك اشخاص وانا لا
اتفاجا الى ما كانوا موجودين في الصين ضد
الحزب الشيوعي الصيني ولكن ما يجري ليس في
الاطار السياسي في حقيقه الامر عدد كبير
من الناس من هذه
التدابير تدابير الاغلاق الى اخره باشارتك
للشباب وان تكون هناك مظاهرات التي
نشاهدها الان في الصين
هل نحن امام ظاهره جديده في الصين
مؤكد عن هذا السؤال ولكنها لحظه مهمه في
الصيد طبعا الصين بلد كبير وهناك دائما
مظاهرات او اعتراضات في مجالات متعدده
ولكن اذا من انتشر هذا الامر في هذه المره
قد يكون هذا الامر غير طبيعي اذا
يا شباب ان همم هناك بعض الاشخاص الذين
يعدون الى سنه 1989
شكرا لك من لندن جاك استاذ الدراسات
الدوليه
الاول في معهد الصين بجامعه فودا
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نرصده مدى انتشار
كورونا ونسال ضيف الحصاد عما اذا كانت
سياسه الاغلاق العامه مفيده في مواجهه
الفيروس
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر امنيه صوماليه ان انفجارين وقع
في فندق روز بالقرب من القصر الرئاسي في
العاصمه مقديشو واضافت المصادر ان
المسلحين يرتدون احزمه ناسفه هاجموا
الفندق الذي يقيم فيه نواف في البرلمان
ومسؤولون في الحكومه ويقع ضمن دائره حمايه
قصر الرئاسي المحصنه وقالت الشرطه
الصوماليه ان الاجهزه الامنيه نجحت في
انقاذ المسؤولين في الحكومه والمواطنين
داخل الفندق وقد اعلنت حركه الشباب
المجاهدين مسؤليتها عن الهجوم وفق ما نشره
موقع محسوب على الحركه
متابعه لهذا الانفجار معنا بالمقديشي
مراسل الجزيره جامع نور جامع ماذا عن هذا
التفجير وماذا خلفه والتعامل معه حتى الان
عبد القادر الى هذه اللحظه وحسب شهود عيان
في المنطقه التي وقع فيها الهجوم لا زالت
هناك اشتباكات وتبادل لاطلاق النار بين
الاجهزه الامنيه الصوماليه وبين العناصر
المهاجمه التي تتحسن داخل هذا الفندق كما
قالت شرطه الصوماليه فان الاجهزه الامنيه
استطاعت ان تخرج المسؤولين الحكوميين
والنواب وكل من كان بداخل هذا الفندق الذي
يقع من ما ذكرتهم في منطقه محصنه وتعد
الحزام الامني بالنسبه للقصر الرئاسي وهي
من المناطق المهمه حيث الوزارات الحكوميه
والبرلمان الصومالي والقصر الرئاسي وايضا
هناك منازل همم التي يسكنها مسؤولون في
الحكومه الصوماليه هذا الانفجار همم
لا توجد حتى الان معلومات رسميه واضحه
لانه همم من الصعب على الاعلاميين الوصول
الى هذه النقطه التي يطلب كل من يصل اليها
ان تكون انت اخو البطاقه حكوميه وغير وغير
ومن لا ومن لا يحمل هذه البطاقه الحكوميه
لا يستطيع الوصول الى هذه المناطق كل
المعلومات المتوفره لدينا هي ان الاجهزه
الامنيه لا زالت تجري هناك مواجهات ما بين
الاجهزه الامنيه والمقتحممين الذين دخلوا
في هذا الفندق اما بالنسبه لما يتعلق
بطبيعه هذا الانفجار هناك تضر في الروايات
هناك من يتحدث انه
ناتج عن همم الرجال كانوا يلبسون احزمه
ناسفه فجروا انفسهم في البوابه الرئيسيه
للفندق وبعدها قاموا باقتحام هناك من
يتحدث ان الانفجار الاول هو ناتج عن سياره
مفخخه شكرا البوابه الرئيسيه للفندق بعد
ذلك حدث هذا الانفجار ودخل هناك بعض
الانباء التي تشير يعني الى اصابه وزير
الامن الصوماليه بجروح في رجله وانه نقل
الى المستشفى
500 من قبل الحدث الذي مازال مستمر
حتى الان جامع نور من مقديش شكرا جزيلا لك
قال رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ان
الاجتماع الثنائي الذي جرى مع الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي بواسطه امير
دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني في
الدوحه كان بهدف في ازاله قطيعه استمرت
تسعه سنين تصريحات الرئيس التركي جاءت
خلال لقائه مع تشكيله حزبه في مدينه
قطر
من امريكا
مع السيد السيسي لمده 30 الى 45 دقيقه
اتفقنا معه على ان تتم الاجتماعات على
مستوى الوزراء وبعدها نرفع مستوى اللقاءات
ونطورها اخبرته ان تركيا مهتمه بازاله
القطيعه والخلاف مع مصر وعدم حصول مشكله
بيننا في البحر الابيض المتوسط كما ناقشنا
كثيرا من المواضيع في اللقاء الثنائي
بيننا في قطر فيما بعد قليل ان السيد
السيسي كان سعيدا جدا بالاجتماع
واعرابها رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان عن
اعتقاده ان العلاقات التركيه السوريه قد
تتحسن مثل ما تحسنت علاقات بلاده مع مصر
ودول الخليج مؤكدا ان السياسه لا تتحمل
القطيعه
ايجابيه
كانت هناك اطراف اراده الاستفاده من
القطيعه التي حصلت بيننا وبين دول الخليج
في فتره ماء الا ان خطاطهم باءت بالفشل
عندما ازلنا القطيع بيننا وكما ان علاقتنا
مع مصر دخلت طريقه تحسن فمن الممكن ان
تدخل علاقتنا مع سوريا في طريق التحسن
ايضا فلا مكان للقطيع في السياسه
قال رئيس الحكومه العراقيه محمد الشياع
السوداني ان الاموال التي سرقت من امانات
دائره الضرائب بلغت ما يوازي نحو مليارين
ونصف المليار دولار امريكي واكد سوداني في
مؤتمر صحفي ان الحكومه استردت جزءا من هذا
المبلغ
نعللكم
عن استرداد جزء من الاموال المسروقه
سرقه الامانات
الضريبيه المبالغ المسروقه مجموعه ثلاثه
مليون
754 مليار
و642 مليون
و664 الف دينار عراقي
معيار
علاقتنا مع كل دول العالم المنطقه والعالم
هو في مدى الاستجابه والتعاون معانا في
استرداد اموال الشعب المسروقه
[موسيقى]
المالك الجديد لتويتر في الوقت الذي قررت
فيه شركات ومؤسسات كثيره وقف اشتراكاتها
الاعلاميه في المنصه بعد سلسله اعضاء
وثغره فنيه خطيره افقدتها ثقه المشتركين
واساءت مكانتها في سوق وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
مستمره واخره بالاتساع تلك الازمه التي
هزت منصه تويتر منذ استحوذ عليها اواخر
اكتوبر الماضي الملياردير الامريكي ايلون
ماسك مقابل 44 مليار دولار
فخلال نحو شهر واحد من ملكيته لها واجهت
شبكه الرائده مشكلات ومازقه لم تشهدها منذ
انشائها لقد بات مصير الموقع من الاساس
موضع نقاش وتكهنات اولى قرارات ماس كانت
تسريحه نصف عدد الموظفين بمنفيهم مدير
سياسات وكبار مسؤولي الرقابه والاداره
المخضرمين قبل ان يلحق بهم مزيد من
زملائهم في موجه استقالات واسعه بسبب
انعدام الامان الوظيفي وسرعان ما حلت
العواقب وخيمه اذا المت الثغرات ولا اعطاب
الفنيه بتويتر بينها توقف عمل النظام
الالي لحقوق الملكيه الفكريه على المنصه
كما تم الابلاغ عن مواجهه مشتركين مصاعب
في تحميل بياناتهم بينما اشتكى اخرون من
قرصنه حساباتهم ومن بطء استعادتها حيث
استغرق الامر اياما في بعض الاحيان
وكان من نتائج تلك الفوضى ان تراجع مستوى
الامان والثقه في تويتر حيث اوقف معلنون
اشتراكاتهم فيه اثر مغادره مسؤوليتي تسويق
كبار المنصه الشهيره كما يثير نظام
التوثيق الجديد الذي يرغب ماسك في تطبيقه
قدرا كبيرا من الارباك وسوء الفهم لا سيما
معتزام الرجل الاثر في العالم فرض رسم
شهري مقداره ثمانيه دولارات لعلامه
التوثيق الزرقاء
حتى الان لا يبدي مالك تويتر الجديد اي
استعداد للتراجع عن خطواته التي يصفها
كثيرون بالمتهوره بل هو من فك يهاجم يوميا
تلك الانتقادات عبر حسابه مستخدما اسلوب
السخريه والاستفزاز اكثر من ذلك يؤكد ماسك
ان استخدامات تويتر زاد في عهده متعهدا
بطرح منتجات جديده على المنصه ومن الخطوات
المثيره للجدل قراره الاسبوع الماضي تفعيل
الحسابات المحظوره بما فيها حساب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
متراجعا عن وجوده السابقه بالا يفعل ذلك
مطلقا
تدابير بررها ماسك بانها استندت الى
استفتاء واسع شارك فيه ملايين المشتركين
لكنها لا تقنع منتقديه الذين يتوقعون
الاسوء لمنصه تويتر قائلين
انون ماسك هو الازمه بحد ذاتها
معنا من فرجينيا
الصحفي المتخصص في القضايا التكنولوجيا في
صحيفه يو اس ستدي والشبكه الاعلاميه
كيف تصف الوضع الحالي لهذه المدرسه منصه
التويتر عقب اقل من شهر من استلام السيد
مصر
غريب
يدعو الى الاستغراب لا نعرف ما يحصل يقول
ان شركه تويتر تنمو وتكبر ولكن يجب ان
نتذكر البدايه الى المعسكر تحدث عن
الحسابات الوهميه المتعدده والروبوتات
الشربكه بشكل كبير يبدو ان شركه تويتر ليس
لديها هذه المشكله الان
وحتى بعد طردي كل هؤلاء الموظفين هذا ما
يقوله وطبعا احنا نتحدث عن شركه تمكنت من
ضبط هذه الحسابات الوهميه ولكن الامر غريب
وملتمس ماليا عندما تخسر هذه الشركه
اكثر من 50 من مجموع مئه من اكبر المعلنين
فيها ما الذي يعنيه ذلك على صعيد مصير هذه
المؤسسه
كبيره هذه المشكله كبيره بالنسبه الى
نموذج الاعمال ان شركه تويتر تبقى شركه
تجني الارباح من خلال الاعلانات المعلنون
يودون ان يفهم التفاصيل ولكن مدير هذه
الشركه يغير القواعد هل سوف يعود ترامب هل
سوف يعود كل من حضر في السابق هل هناك
عوده على السياسات الماضيه وبالتالي
الجهات المعلنه وهو امر مفهوم
تتخذ اجراءات بابطاء الانفاق في هذا
المجال او الانسحاب منه يجب ان نتذكر ان
ايرون ماسك لا يستخدم
فقط بل لديه قرود قيل له اذا تصل الى
مليار دولار بالسنه فوائدها وبالتالي لا
يمكنه ان يسحب الاموال من محفظته الشخصيه
الى فتره غير محدوده من فرجينيا همم
روبابيجريرو والصحفيه المتخصص في القضايا
التكنولوجيا في صحيفه يو اس توداي وصل
الشبكه الاعلاميه ليغو شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نعود الى اكبر احتجاجات تشهدها الصين منذ
عقود ضد الاجراءات الحكوميه الصارمه
لاحتواء فيروس كورولا الشراره كانت من
مدينه اورنج باقليم
حيث ان دلع حريق في مبنى سكني قبل ايام
اشير الى ان اجزاء كبيره من اقليم وعصبته
اورميتشي قد اغلقت لاكثر من 100 يوم الى
مدينه وهران وسط الصين التي شهدت اليوم
احتجاجات على القيود الصحيه بعد نحو ثلاثه
اعوام من رصد اول اصابه بكورو ناضم او على
مستوى العالم في هذه المدينه
شرقا الى وسط شينغهاي التي شهدت ايضا
احتجاجات ثابته
ظهرالها المحتجون وهم يحملون اوراقا بيضاء
في خطوه اصبح رمز للاحتجاج على الرقابه في
الصين كما نظمت وقفه احتجاجيه في جامعه
بيجين واظهرت مقاطع مصوره وقفه الاحتجاجيه
ضخمه في معهد الاتصالات في نانجينغ شرقي
شرقا وتجمعات في شيان في وسط البلاد و
جوانغو في الجنوب
هذا ما يحدث في الصين بسبب الاجراءات
الحكوميه
لتجنب انتشار اوسع ليكوفيت 19 والسؤال
الذي يفرض نفسه ماذا عن الوضع في باقي
الدول العالم
اظهرت احداث البيان احداث البيانات ان
اجماليه عدد الاصابات المؤكده بفايروس
كورونا في انحاء العالم تخطى 641 مليون
اصابه
وتشيروا بيانات على موقع جامعه الامريكيه
ان ارتفاع اجمالي الوفيات جراء الجائحه في
العالم الى اكثر من سته ملايين و600
و30,000
واذا كانت الصين قد سجلت اليوم اصابات
جديده بفايروس كورولا تتجاوزوا 39,000 في
اليابان مثلا سجلت اليوم الاحد
98,000 اصابه جديده بالفيروس
نعود الى الوضع عالميا في التاسع من الشهر
الجاري افادت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان عدد
الوفيات الناجمه عن الاصابه بكرونا انخفض
بشده منذ الشتائه الماضي المنظمه قدرت
الانفاضه في حالته الوفاه بنحو 90% مقارنه
بحاله الوفاه غير شباط الماضي الذي شهد
ذروه الوفيات بسبب كره
للمزيد عن هذه العالميه فيما يتعلق
بانتشار والتحكم في انتشار الكوفي 19 معنا
من باريس من ليون الفرنسيه البروفيسور
يحيى عبد المؤمن المكي استاذ علم
الفيروسات والخبير السابق لدى منظمه الصحه
اهلا بك وقد يبدو السؤال المنطقي الذي
يتبادل الاذهان الان فيما رفعت تقريبا كل
دول العالم الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالكوفي الصين تقوم بعمليات الاغلاق صحيه
كيف نفهم ذلك
تحياتي
لكل هذا الاستاذ عبد القادر بانه الصين
تضرب اليوم بالعمق بهذه
الكورونا الموسميه الى ان نقول اليوم
اصبحت موسميه بنت شعرها في العالم تقريبا
كله اشكرك على التقرير الذي قدمته وهو
يعني يعطينا نظره حقيقيه على انتشاره
الصين اليوم لانه عدد الاصابات ترتفعت جدا
بسبب عوده الموسم الخريف الشتاء والاكتئاب
السكاني والاحتكاك ما بين الاشخاص وخاصه
كذلك مع الاحتكاك في المزارع مع الحيوانات
تربيه الدواجن تربيه الخنازير مع عده
حيوانات ثدييه وكذلك بالنسبه لباقي الدول
الاسيويه او الاوروبيه لانه الارتفاع كما
ذكرت في اليابان في سنغافوره في عده دول
اوروبا
خمسه ايام على التوالي ما يفكر 44 الف
صعبه يوميا والدليل بانه الفيروس ما زال
منتشرا الوفيات اقل لكن الاصابات
ويؤدي الى همم
الدخول الى المستشفى ما زالت حاله في
الاسعافات وفي العنايه المركزه لانه عندنا
سواء اشخاص لم يتلقحوا تماما واصيبوا او
اشخاص كبار السن ولهم امراض مزمنه فهم في
الاصابات لكن في نفس الوقت انتشرت
الفيروسات العاديه الى ان نقول الموسميه
الانفلونزا الف خاصه عند الاطفال
المستشفيات مختلفه في اوروبا وفي فرنسا
الذي يعطي التهاب عند الخلايا الرئويه
وقسمات الرئويه المنخفضه اطفال هذه كلها
السبب الرئيسي هو رفعنا الحاجبنا القناع
بينما الصين فرضت هذا الحجر واصبحت اليوم
مظاهرتي انه
الصينيين راح انه همم اغلقت اوروبا واسيبت
فلا داعي للاغلاق والاغلاق اليوم حتى بعد
الاغلاق ما يفوق 60,000 حالا همم منذ
اسبوعين تقريبا متتاليه
وربما الارقام تنقسيوم الى 30000 وتسعد
بعد يوم به الى 60 او 70,000 التخوف الصين
للاغلاق الصين مدينه نتكلم عن 20 مليون
نسمه في مدينه واحده فالاغلاق هو ليس
اغلاق الشيء باكمله بينما التخوف من كثره
الاصابات واذا اصيب 20 مليون شخص فالغياب
عن العمل
وربما الاكتئاب في المستشفيات
القطاع الصحي في الصين
نعم نعم
الشرطه الى مساله الفيروسات الموسميه ال-
ال- الاخرى
التركيز ما زال الى الان على موضوع همم
كورونا ايضا كيف نفهم ذلك في ظل هذه
الوجود هذه الفيروسات الاخرى
احسن جدا هو كل من يصاب بالسعال والحمى
والضرر في الجهاز التنفسي والتعب والضرر
في الاعضاء هو فيروس من الفيروسات الحل
الوحيد لكي نفرز ما بين هل هذا كوبيد او
هل هذا انفلونزا الف الف او الف اثنين او
الف باء او ااه انفلونزا او فيروس اخر
رينو فايروس
بيسمى البي سي ار مختلفه انواع الاحمر
تعطينا في نفس العيني كريم همم اربع ساعات
نحلل نجد من هو موسى
بالكوفيرا وعند الاطفال نظرا في الحضانه
وفي المدارس الابتدائيه
اطفال الذين يدخلون العنايه المركزه
مصابين بالثلاث فيروسات
لانه اصبحنا نعيش عاديه في هذا الشكر فتح
ناكم السبب الرئيسي لهذه الانتشار العدوى
والامراض التي انتشرت في بسرعه
في سوريا يحيى عبد المؤمن مكي استاذ علم
الفيروسات والخبيره السابقه عند منظمه
الصحه العالميه شكرا جزيلا لك
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه اليكم
موجز لاهم الانباء قبل جولتنا الرياضيه
يوميات الماضيه
قال رئيس تركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان لبلاده
حقا مشروعا في التحرك خارج الحدود لحمايه
املها وفي اشاره للعمليه العسكريه التي
تشلها قوه بلاده في شمال سوريا والعراق
قال الرئيس التركي انه ليس بامكان احد
منعه انقره من استخدام هذا الحقه
وجاء ذلك بالتزامن مع توسيع القوات
التركيه المواقع التي استهدفتها في الشمال
السوري مؤكده مواصله عمليتها ضد من سمتهم
الارهابيين في شمال سوريا والعراق كما
اعلنت القوه التركيه مقتله احد جنودها
برصاص مسلح حزب العمال الكردستاني فيما
قالت ما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه ان
القصف التركي يشمل
حلب ومناطق عده في الرقه والحسكه
هذا المتحدث باسمي الكريم ان هناك خلافات
مع تركيا بشان سوريا لكنه اضاف ان مستوى
العلاقات البلدين والحكمه السياسيه يسمحان
بحل كل هذه الخلافات من خلال محادثات
مكثفه
في اوكرانيا تحتضم المعارك على طول خط
الجبهه في اقليم ادومباز وتبادلت القوات
الروسيه والاكرانيه القصف في خيرسون حيث
تحاول القوات الاخرانيه ضربه طرق الامداد
بين نهر دنبر والقرد اما القوات الروسيه
فتسعى الى ضرب البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها صدت هجمات اوكرانيه على مستوى على
محوري
دنياز كالمواليه لروسيا ان قصف المدفعيا
الاوكرانيا استهدف مباليه سكنيه وسط
المدينه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه امداد
القوات الاخرانيه بصوارخ ارض جو عاليه
الدقه من طراز برنستون 2 كجزء من حزمه
مساعدتها العسكريه لاوكرانيا وقالت
الوزاره
الحاسما في عرقله التقدم الروسيه
اندلعت احتجاجات في مدينه شنغهاي الصينيه
للمطالبه برفع القيود المشدده المفروضه
منذ ثلاث سنوات من قبل السلطات الصينيه
بسبب تفشي فايروس كورونا وتوسعت المظاهرات
الى مدن اخرى بينها وغام انتشار الفيروس
وياتي ذلك وسط التقارير رسميه افادت
بتسجيل الصين اكثر من 36 الف اصابه اليوم
الاحد
قالت مصادر امنيه صوماليه ان انفجارين وقع
في فندق الواقع ضمن دائره حمايه قصر
الرئاسيه المحسنه في العاصمه مقديشو
واضافت المصادر ان مهاجمين يرتدون احزمه
الناسفه هاجموا الفندق الذي يقيم فيه نواب
في البرلمان ومسؤولون في الحكومه ولم يبلغ
عن وقوعه اصابته وقد اعلنت حركه الشباب
المجاهدين
عن الهجوم
كتاب الحصاد شكرا على متابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]